[Music]
dear city leaders politicians decision
makers in the name of all cyclists I
have an important message for you this
is not bicycle infrastructure this is a
constant near-death experience for
Adrenaline Junkies this is proper
bicycle infrastructure physically
separated from high-speed motor traffic
or this even not as good but at least
cars don't have to constantly Dodge you
what you don't like fearing for your
life when cars pass you by at high speed
at Arms
no not really I'm weird like that as a
rule of thumb if you can't imagine
groups like pensioners or school
children cycling on a given bike path
it's a bad bike path bike infrastructure
shouldn't be tailored solely around fit
young adult men in professional biking
gear who have nothing to fear or nothing
to lose so here's what you should be
doing take a road take one lane separate
it from the rest and turn it into a
dedicated bike lane congratulations you
now have proper bike infrastructure that
people can safely use on an everyday
basis without the fear of death this has
been a message from cyclists to City
decision makers thank you for your kind
attention